what about this Chuck Schumer guy dude I
keep everybody I hear about he just like
has like the whole Democratic party like
he's just a Wall Street guy but like
healthare he just has it all [__]
well Chuck Schumer's one of those guys
who like it's sick he's like the jaedo
of dirty Healthcare BR yeah cuz he's a
you know he's like beholden to Wall
Street and the big companies it's just
sick man they're all old dude all these
Boomers need to step aside our country's
being run by like 80-year-old Boomers
well there's no way it just everything
this guy's doing it just seems like it's
all crime it's all crime yeah that's
what I feel like it's all crime we're
being it's all Batman villains yes it's
all Batman villains it's like Dick Tracy
villain remember that like the yeah lips
lips manless yeah and the prune yeah
it's like that's who this is the prune
there's eyebrows Harper right there and
they're like out here telling us can we
watch whatever he's
saying
this woman has a crazy jaw this is about
uh Chuck Schumer he's like she's got
like a Matt rif jaw yeah she looks like
woman is carved um she looks like uh
Schwarzenegger's ex-wife Shriver maybe
yeah Maria Shriver she does have a
little bit of that she's got a very
strong drw the nicotine pouches pose a
danger to teens as they use them as an
alternative to ecigarettes pouch packed
with problems high levels of nicotine so
today I'm delivering a warning to
parents [__] this guy now he's selling
you know he's selling on young teen and
even lower right after this press
conference he's got a garbage bag full
of Vapes and he takes them out back and
just sells them to kids oh yeah he
there's no by the way he'll get like The
Vape people will call him and donate a
lot of money to him and like the next
week he'll be out there he'll be like
you know kids are very stressed out yeah
and is it the worst thing in the world
that they go out and take a puff couple
puffs off a pineapp father they have the
saddest names yeah right because this
the worst thing in the world to relieve
a little stress yeah watermelon hope you
didn't get ass to your eighth grade
dance yeah you want to go out there and
just blow a little air you want to suck
a little cranberry prom [__] a little
peach peach
smoke oh this guy is uh well this Artic
this right here this is about the um are
they saying they're outlawing zins where
at in New York Nick yeah they want uh
the FDA to look into it um saying
they're trying to sell the children dude
[__] this guy this guy there's no
nothing about this guy to me seems
trustworthy at all he's not he doesn't
care he doesn't you're right he's
selling something on the back end he has
some back deal he's like there people
are coming to him going like this Zin
stuff's [__] up our stuff he's like
okay he doesn't care Chuck Schumer
doesn't care if kids are addicted to
drugs no he does not care at all nope
it's just I mean but he's the one I
think that has a lot to do with the
monopolizing of the uh well he's you
know that's the thing man he's just
basically like hey I'm here to tell you
that I'm four people and he's been in
there forever you're not supposed to be
there forever so dirty that guy's been
in there forever do you know how dirty
you have to be to be in there
forever he's forever in there yeah get
him out man that's the number one rule
uh Wall Street money Reigns on Schumer
yeah 11 million on the Senate since the
beginning of the year and this 2009 this
guy's been doing this forever wow
imagine how much money this [__] dirt
ball is [__] guy has been doing this
forever if you have anything to do with
this dude to me feels like [__] bad
news bro and you know his his niece is a
comedian she really Ali Wong oh I didn't
even know that and she's in beef
too I'm obviously joke it's not Ali Wong
it's the one with the same name yeah
yeah but it's not her fault no it's no
one's fault well what he's doing is his
fault it's his fault but um if he gave a
[__] about health unless she's selling
Vapes right be crazy right yeah if she's
in the Zin business women's Li puffers
she's like selling Zin
and to women who've been like victims of
sexual assault she's like they should
have the right to Puff they should have
the right to Zin Puff the paint away
yeah healthy sex is the flavor of it
yeah healthy sex kiwi um
but no dude if that guy thinks he's
gonna take zins away bro he's out of his
bro dude that's not the big imagine
looking at the world and going the
biggest problem is zins do you know how
crazy you have to be like it's like
Gavin Nome like they were trying to ban
I forget what they were trying to ban
but they were all going nuts about
something in California I'm like there's
there's a there's people like straight
up on a 101 running across it with their
dog in their hands yeah yeah here we go
they're banning these food chemicals
which is good that's all nice right
California governor Gavin Newsome has
signed a lion Mark law aimed at Banning
red die number three and other
potentially harmful food additives and
consumer goods it's like okay that's
great but also like how about we address
some of the other issues if you want to
take Zen away from you're taking [__]
Zen the last thing that's keeping people
going to college people need to choose
something at this point in their lives
we have adult males that whose wives
have left them they Zen body pillows
right that's all they can do yeah you
can't you will never take our Zen that
guy dude you have better luck taking
guns from people than zins right Zin
people need it in fact I think I would
load a gun with zins right walk into a
caig house and just fired into the jaws
of everybody in there I'm 1,000% with
you you cannot take the [__] the last
thing that they have no you can't you
know it's just all dirty Healthcare I
wonder how though that's what I don't
know they Feed Us Poison so we buy their
cures I don't know what the bottom
says but it says Siran Shan supports
RFK